I think I gotta come clean with you  about that  what I told you about my brother yeah I  told you about the program he's forced  to attend a now he shouldn't be there  don't count your chickens before they do  you understand that no something  happened I'll know exactly what an  arrest is being held at Rikers Island we  get killed in there all right you just  have a client that walked in again get  another ten grand your boat will get out  where are you how much money can you get  right now come on bro oh my gosh you  kidding me  you think I'm doing this for you I want  to be in a play  [Music]  [Music]  don't be confused just going to make the  worse to me every time before okay I  want you to come here now you are gonna  love it  this place where we are now and be a lot  of fun if you ever you're going to have  a good time  [Music]  you  you